hey sarge he made my computer smarter
all i have to do is put my thumb on that
thing and it opens up all my electric
mails
you seem real smart man oh look can you
play with toys
savant you're part of the 99 now we look
after each other
hey ball if savant was to do anything to
harm this precinct
would i destroy him
answer uncertain try again
um so we've developed a revenue sharing
formula
that will hopefully appeal to most
business owners leslie
go home you're sick i'm not sick it's
just allergies come on guys just let me
in there
no you can't come in here you're not
coming in melissa you you look tired and
you're all sweaty
you look tired and you're all sweaty all
the time what's your excuse you want to
go there jerry
no i'm sorry are you leaving i thought
we had a meeting no we do it's just i
think it's a little chilly in here
are you okay your eyes are glassy oh my
god oh my is she she's sick
are you sick no yeah she's sick
that's why i'm wearing this and misting
myself with hand sanitizer
i'm not sick i just have allergies okay
i took a claritin and i threw that up so
i took another one i threw that up
and then i took a third and it stayed
down i'm getting better
all right you're burning up you're
burning up what
i have to get out of here i have 2.8
body fat
my body's like a microchip a grain of
sand could destroy it
my body's a microchip
leslie go home no i can't i can't go
home i have to get ready for the chamber
of secrets commerce if this meeting does
not go perfectly then the harvest
festival is going to be over before it
began i cannot go home
okay then who is your doctor ann's my
doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world come on
oh no i'm hot now it's really hot okay
well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
104.1 leslie you're dehydrated i'm
admitting you
if i was sick could i do this
what are you doing cartwheels
am i not doing them no ben wyatt hello
uh hi leslie good to see you
wow you're really burning up can i get
some money for
the cab that i took over here please
sure how much i'm not sure
i looked at the meter and it had
egyptian hieroglyphics on it
do you know the exchange rate so should
we do this
oh boy hold on be careful what
the floor on the wall just switched
okay walk very carefully
you know i find it a little insulting
that you don't trust me to handle this
it's not i don't trust you okay it's
just this
harvest festival is my project it's my
career on the line
and i just need to make sure that i've
done everything i can to make it work
okay it's show time
okay good evening everyone i'm leslie
monster and this
is nightline every one of you just by
showing up here tonight
has already made history in days past
the harvest festival was the cornerstone
of pawnee's small business
community a week-long showcase for
everything from textiles to small farms
by our estimates as many as 30 000
people might attend the festival and the
monetary value of that kind of direct
customer to business exposure is frankly
incalculable
the time is now the place is pawnee
let's make history
you must be ron swanson well welcome to
casa ludgate
hello mr ludger ah call me larry larry
who is it
it's zuzu's boss oh ron rita ludgate
oh you have no idea how nice it is to
meet you
but oh come in for god's sake what can i
get you to drink ooh
could you take your shoes off please
thank you so much
uh nothing to drink thanks oh okay is
april around
uh zuzu you have a guest well i'll fetch
her
she's probably on the internet again
i'll come with you okay
okay uh you make yourself at home mr
swanson thank you
you must be april's sister i'm ron
nice to meet you why are you here
come back to work nah
come back i want you to come back
well i don't want to come back the end
i was talking to andy about you and he
made me realize that i need you back at
work
what did he say don't recall fine i'll
come back
good okay i'm leaving
bye zuzu bye duke silver
my mom has all your albums i recognize
you the day we met
have you told anyone no
good girl
ah captain you're at my desk just what i
want to see first thing in the morning
you're three minutes late peralta
not my fault i had a plumbing problem
[Music]
which reminds me i'm going to need a new
departmentally issued phone
oh come on really i'm a few minutes late
so you're going to call me out in front
of everyone
good idea everyone gather round so i can
call out peralta in front of you okay
fine i was three minutes late i'm sorry
for doing one thing wrong oh it's more
than one thing
let's start with the kristoff murder
there's an amazing solve i got him to
confess in 20 minutes
you also mislabeled the evidence so that
confession is worthless if the sergeant
hadn't caught your mistake
here are three cases with sloppy
paperwork here are two pictures
one is your locker the other is a
garbage dump in the philippines
can you tell which is which
that one's the dump they're both your
locker i should have guessed that he's
good
this folder is labeled undies comma
dirty
so i won't confuse it with undies comma
clean also who cares about all these
rules i have more felony arrests than
any other detective here
you also have more mice living in your
desk than any other detective
algernon you guys algernon's back
get rid of the mouse and get your act
together now
he's grumpy okay this is it
ryan is doing my intro right now dunder
mifflin
can't compete with the modern chains and
management is unwilling
or unable to adapt their customers are
dying off
i can't hear what he's saying but he
looks like he's really into it
and now without further ado i present
the regional manager of dunder mifflin
scranton
michael scott
[Music]
hello everyone i am michael scott
and i'd like to start today by
inspiring you may i
borrow someone's textbook please
thank you what have we here oh
economics very very interesting
you cannot learn from books
replace these pages with
life lessons and then
you will have a book
that is worth its weight in gold
i know these are expensive um but the
lesson is priceless
good all right i think you're inspired
shall we proceed there are four kinds of
business
tourism food service
railroads and sales
and hospitals slash manufacturing
and air travel so
you want to start a business how do you
start what do you need
well first of all you need a building
and secondly you need supply you need
something to sell now this could be
anything it could be a
thingamajig or a hoozie whatsie
or a whatchamacallit
now you need to sell those
in order to have a payday
and if you sell enough of them
you will make a 100
grand
satisfied
you